[Applause]
[Music]
new releases is here to answer the tough
questions
where did Professor Layton go what's
really out there in space and most
importantly are you a squid or a kid
make sure you hit that subscribe button
to get the answers each and every Sunday
now let's check out some of the coolest
games dropping this week real talk
splatoon too should have been called
splatoon that aside pretty much
everything you'd want from the splat
filled sequel is here
the new co-op mode salmon run will let
you team up with buddies to fight back
the sinister salmonids and you can do it
with new weapons like the splat Dooley's
and remixed fan favorites like this
splat roller and splat charger thanks to
the switches portability you can take
the action anywhere just make sure
you're very clear when you tell your
roommate you've been splatting in the
bathroom splatoon two drops on Friday
July 21st but you can check out plenty
of gameplay on GameSpot right now yonder
the cloud capture chronicles also
features a cutesy art style but this
open world is a lot less goopy picture a
harvest moon or star to valley but on a
massive continent with different
environments like fields and jungles and
snowy mountains some sort of darkness
has fallen over this land and you'll
have to use a combination of farming
crafting and building relationships with
the locals to fix it
yonder comes to ps4 and PC on Tuesday
July 18 now let's talk about a way less
peaceful world fallen Legion is actually
two separate action RPGs that tell the
same story but from opposing sides the
ps4 version sins of an empire puts you
in the role of princess Cecile an
empress charged with restoring a fallen
Kingdom all the while dealing with a
military coup and in the Vita version
flames of rebellion you'll actually be
leading that coup both versions feature
beautiful hand-drawn art and multiple
playable characters and they both
launched on Tuesday the 18th that's
pretty good timing with Game of Thrones
premiering over the weekend
when you play fallen Legion you win will
you die virtual reality is all about
transporting you to other places and
lone echo takes you all the way to the
rings of Saturn something weird is
happening at the mining facility there
so you'll have to float around the space
station and other out-of-this-world
environments solve puzzles and figure
out what's really going on in space no
one can hear you scream but they might
still hear an echo yeah that sounded a
lot better in my head
anyway lone Echo comes to the oculus
rift on Thursday the 20th and finally
there's another bunch of puzzles to
solve this week
Layton's mystery journey catriel and the
millionaire's conspiracy stars Layton's
daughter Kat who's on a quest to figure
out why her father has vanished she's
joined by her talking dog Shirl and her
friends Emiliana and Ernest the
millionaire's conspiracy comes to iOS
and Android devices on the 20th but
you'll have to wait till later this year
for the 3ds version in the West and
those are the biggest games we'll be
playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listing to enter subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with more games next week